[Music]
what's up wisecrack michael here to talk
about everyone's favorite yuletide
underdog or uh under deer that's right
rudolph santa's red nose minion who was
best memorialized in that 1964 stop
motion animated special it's a
heartwarming depiction of our scrappy
little friend finding acceptance in his
community despite being a bioluminescent
freak
but what if the movie can accidentally
teach us about the dystopia of modern
life
allow us to ruin your childhood in this
wisecrack edition on the philosophy of
rudolph the red-nosed reindeer and of
course spoilers ahead before we get too
deep into the world of stop-motion
holiday cinema i wanted to take a second
to talk about my favorite island of
misfit toys the wisecrack patreon it's a
community of folks who have no problem
finding the deepest of meanings in the
weirdest of places not to mention you
get to watch all of our videos early and
without ads you also get exclusive
access to the wisecrack discord where
you can connect with like-minded folks
and even share takes with wisecrack
hosts and writers to give you a free
preview here are some of my hot takes on
christmas movies
die hard doesn't actually count as a
christmas movie but in bruges absolutely
does four christmases is an underrated
classic exploring the fluidity of the
american family the night before is a
great movie to watch with your
grandparents and or young children and
home alone joe pesci is actually the
good guy and until jeff bridges plays
santa in a movie i'm not interested in
any cinematic representations of kris
kringle
for takes like these and ones that are
even worse go to patreon.com wisecrack
and join today membership start at just
two dollars it's the holiday gift you
deserve to give yourself so go to
patreon.comwisecrack today now back to
the show but first a quick recap rudolph
follows the adventures of the eponymous
reindeer who is born with one very
prominent trait he's he's got a shiny
nose shiny i'd even say it glow
but instead of being celebrated for his
gift rudolph receives a crash course and
feeling ashamed of his body taught by
his own father you'll like it and wear
it
it's not very comfortable there are more
important things than comfort rudolph is
instructed to hide his shame but of
course you can't keep an incandescent
nose hidden for long once his cover is
blown our hero finds himself ruthlessly
mocked to the point where he enters a
self-imposed exile on the road rudolph
teams up with a fellow north pole weirdo
hermie the elf on their journey the two
meet the prospector yukon cornelius
narrowly avoid the abominable snow
monster and end up at this surreal place
the island of misfit toys eventually
though rudolph realizes that he can't
keep running away from his problems and
decides to return home the only problem
his family has been captured by the
abominable snow monster but with help
from his friends rudolph is able to save
his family and live happily ever after
well almost after a last minute
snowstorm hits the north pole grounding
santa's sleigh it seems like christmas
will be cancelled everything's
all
grounded
poor kids that is until old kris kringle
realizes he's got a pair of headlights
in the form of rudolph that knows
that beautiful wonderful nose rudolph
then leads the team santa picks up all
the misfit toys and christmas is saved
the story's takeaway seems to be
bullying people for being different is
not cool so uh
case closed
not quite incidentally rudolph is also a
weird master class in the dystopian
reality of what philosopher michel
foucault called biopower or biopolitics
basically if being in charge used to
mean beheading your subjects when they
were naughty modern government power is
about the management of life aka
biopolitics it's about keeping a
well-fed disease-free population who can
show up to work on time and go fight in
a war if you need them to but what
happens when people resist being managed
when they either can't or won't be good
productive citizens enter deviancy or
the violation of social norms since that
deviance is a threat to the biopolitical
order it must be policed historically
these deviants were criminal misfits or
labeled mad or considered physically
unfit to do the work or unwilling to do
the whole be heterosexual and make
babies thing on the flip side of
deviancy in biopolitics is normalization
reforming criminals and sexual deviants
and so on so that they can be integrated
into society now you might be wondering
what this all has to do with rudolph it
might seem like a stretch but throughout
its 50-minute run time almost every
single major plot point explores how
biopower normalizes and disciplines
deviants social norms in christmas town
are pretty simple wake up and do your
part to make christmas happen for the
kids for example be an elf making toys
and these norms work great for their
leader santa whose primary aim is you
know
christmas for whatever reason even when
the elves aren't on the job santa
ensures that they remain loyal tireless
workers by having them participate in
elf practice which by the way is totally
not brainwashing we work hard all day
but our work is played but it doesn't
just stop there reindeer for example can
fly and so santa has created a
regimented training program to take
advantage of this trait our first game
is called takeoff we all want to pull
santa suede someday don't we in the
north pole it's not crazy to say that a
reindeer's whole existence revolves
around working for santa just look at
the moment rudolph is born well donner
where's the new member of the family
after all if he's going to be on my team
someday he'd better get to know me but
what happens when someone deviates from
the norm take hermie rudolph's elf
friend who would rather be a dentist
than a toy smith for whatever reason
dentistry isn't exactly considered a
social utility in the north pole so he
is basically ostracized from the social
order rudolf's nose isn't a hindrance to
his job function but his physical
abnormality gets aggressively policed by
his family and his fellow juvenile
reindeer despite both our heroes having
very real ways in which they could
contribute to society they're deemed to
have little to no social value because
they don't fit in it's like he said i'll
never fit in in effect rudolph and
hermie are what scholars david t
mitchell and sharon l snyder would call
non-productive bodies or those who have
been shunned largely by virtue of
biological incapacity aesthetic
non-conformity and or non-normative
labor patterns and what does the
biopolitical state of christmas town do
to non-productive bodies it expels them
or treats them with such hostility that
they expel themselves hermie for example
leaves after his boss threatens to fire
him for giving adult teeth they don't
even ask the question why can't our
society handle more dalty
and rudolph is told that he's forbidden
to practice with other reindeer all
right all right now earnings back to
practice
oh no not you
you better go home with your folks from
now on gang we won't let rudolph join in
any reindeer games right
also did we mention that santa is kind
of a dick here donner you should be
ashamed of yourself what a pity he had a
nice takeoff too but it's not just
rudolph and hermie who are expelled from
society in fact the outside world is
teeming with other non-productive bodies
perhaps nothing embodies this better
than the entire island of misfit toys in
the platonic ideal of toy-ness a toy's
job is to bring a child happiness as
such toys who are unable to fill this
role are useless and are therefore cast
away for such trivialities as having the
wrong name my name is don't tell me
jack no
charlie
that's why i'm a misfit toy
my name is all wrong no child wants to
play with a charlie in the box
philosopher anna salmezzi calls this
process biopolitical abandonment the
process by which people who refuse to
conduct themselves properly place
themselves outside of the population and
thus are no longer deemed worthy of
society's care or protection the core
logic of biopolitics as selmesi notes of
foucault is not only the fostering of
some forms of life but the disavow of
others even to the point of death like
that weird team-building exercise when
you have to pretend you and your
co-workers are stuck on a life raft and
you have to awkwardly decide who doesn't
get a life preserver as you sink to your
watery grave
am i the only one who did that
it was weird because i said me and then
everyone just got really sad but i
thought i was taking one for the team i
don't work there anymore in the case of
the misfit toys that means being
abandoned to some weird leper colony but
hey rudolph is about how this stuff is
bad the film has a happy ending in which
everyone apologizes to rudolph and
hermie for treating them so poorly if
anything rudolph is the celebration of
the things that make us different
right well yes and that makes it even
more interesting that's because it not
only shows us how biopolitics manages
deviancy but how it can end up
incorporating it first and foremost it's
important to note that when rudolph
finally comes back
nothing is different he's still the
object of scorn in the north pole hey
look who's back oh neon now
even more depressing santa seems to only
care about rudolph's return insofar as
it benefits his mission with rudolph's
father out looking for him santo will be
down a worker come christmas christmas
eve is only two days off and without
your father i'll never be able to get my
sleigh off the ground and maybe most
depressingly still rudolph is only
hailed as a hero when the very nose that
he was vilified for becomes socially
useful suddenly rudolph goes from being
a non-productive body to being a hero i
knew that nose would be useful someday i
knew it all along rudolph's
transformation from scorned misfit to
savior of christmas can best be
understood as a rehabilitation or what
mitchell and snyder call a productive
process of recovery leading to a return
to employment in the activities of civic
life in other words rehabilitation
amounts to an economic transformation
and it's one that all the misfits
undergo in this film for example yukon
cornelius claims that he's reformed the
now toothless abominable snow monster i
reform this bumble he wants a job
[Applause]
once the scourge of the north now the
monster is toothless and capable of
being assimilated into the biopolitical
order and then there are the misfit toys
after sansa confidently promises to find
children who would want to play with
them rudolph i promise as soon as this
storm lets up i'll find homes for all
those misfit toys the misfit toys see an
elevation in their social status in
short because santa decreed it so
they're wanted again and as such they're
reintroduced into society well let's be
on our way finally there's herme who
finds himself rehabilitated when the
head elf apparently realizing the
cavities are a thing allows him to open
his own dental practice i better set up
an appointment for you week from tuesday
this then is the logic of biopolitics
expel the non-productives or at least
abandon them if you can normalize them
take away their teeth and rough edges so
they can become a productive member of
society however society defines that but
biopower is a technology and one that's
always shifting so yes your tooth fetish
might have made you a freak a few months
ago but now that we can put it to use
welcome aboard the same applies to
rudolph's nose which once they realize
it can help santa navigate the snowstorm
suddenly becomes highly valuable it
reflects the ongoing process in the real
world in which behaviors and attributes
that were once labeled deviant can be
assimilated into the productive order
people once thought incorrectly that gay
people were a threat to the social
fabric particularly in the army but once
the military realized that they could be
drone pilots too
inclusion became a strength and so like
rudolph's red nose different categories
of so-called deviants can be accepted
into the social order on account of
their differences but what do you guys
think is christmastown actually a utopia
where everyone can contribute with their
own unique traits or is this classic
christmas tale actually a grim
demonstration of how biopower functions
in the modern world let us know in the
comments huge thanks to our patrons for
all your support hit that subscribe
button like your social worth depends on
it and don't forget to ring that bell
and as always thanks for watching later
[Music]
you